the kamarauti bazaar district in
turkey's aegean coastal city izmir
the historical area's roots reach back
to ancient times
but anthropologist nesim benjuya is
looking for different routes
namely traces of his own jewish
ancestors
the residence you see down there is a
so-called jews court from the ottoman
period
the jews themselves called these houses
they came to the ottoman empire from
spain
returned to his hometown izmir in 2010.
like many turkish jews he had previously
immigrated to israel
in izmir he's been working with the
foundation to save the architectural
remnants of jewish life here in
particular the city's remaining
synagogues
[Music]
most of them are in the former jewish
quarter which is now a poorer area
i'd like to turn these sites of jewish
life into spaces for art and culture
that would also benefit the district
because it
he shows us one of the six remaining
synagogues
the hope is that one day it will host
exhibitions and
concerts the building is hardly more
than a ruin
but it dates back to the byzantine era
the debris was meters high
with trees already growing on it
the roof was long gone
and look here
the initiative has been getting plenty
of support including from germany
most muslim residents here also stand
behind the project
they hope it will bring in more tourists
tourists appreciate the history more
than we the quarters residents do
but
but there are also anti-semites in
turkey
when israeli president isaac herzog came
to istanbul in mid-march a demonstration
was held outside a synagogue where he
was attending a prayer service
an anti-semitic prejudice is easy to
find on istanbul streets
money rules the world and since the jews
have so much of it they end up ruling
the world
we show the jewish faith respect
but they have no regard for our religion
it's clear that they rule the world it's
a few powerful families who do that okay
has heard these prejudices before
they are one reason why he organizes
tours of izmir's former jewish quarter
for his turkish countrymen
for most of them it's the first time
they see a synagogue from the inside
that's the first step
the next time they might attend one of
our cultural events
currently there's a debate and honest
conversation being held about
discrimination and violence that
non-muslim minorities suffered in the
past
[Applause]
one catalyst for this seems to have been
the popular turkish streaming series the
club
[Applause]
the series dramatized real-life attacks
on christians and jews in 1955.
vendriya was a young boy at the time
a potentially violent mob had gathered
on one of the city squares
my mother rushed over to the neighbours
with me
i remember her shouting that people were
running through the streets
and that they might
when i watched the part of the series
that dealt with those events
all the fear i experienced as a little
boy came back to me
as a consequence of the harassment and
discrimination many jews left turkey
today only about twenty thousand remain
in the entire country and barely one
thousand in izmir
each term is the choke yesterday
only the older ones among us are still
here
hardly any of the 30 and 40 year olds
are left at all
and we're having one funeral after
another
is one of very few jews who have
returned and he wants to ensure that at
least the cultural heritage of izmir's
once proud and thriving jewish community
is preserved